on this episode it got so crazy I
decided to make a t-shirt about episode
158
[Music]
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 158 of
the askgaryvee show
it is a Halloween edition and I guess
Steve and I decided to dress a Casper
yeah at least India
brought a little Thunder for Halloween
and we have a pumpkin got pumpkins so
they gotta count for something
it is also Friday which means I get my
official prediction and truth be told
I've been very hectic I was in Buffalo
for two days big shout out to Buffalo
had a great time up there for the 43
north startup competition great company
received a million dollars last name
it's kind of crazy actually to think
about it um got this got the co judge
with a bunch of great people including
my good friend Mike Lazar alpha on her
buddy media so that was a lot of fun for
me love you'll as if you're watching us
and so that's it and where I was going
with that was I actually don't know what
my prediction for the Jets Raiders game
is going to be for all of you I know I
know everybody's betting heavy this week
given that I am 6 for 6 so I want to
give that little bit of context because
I think I've thought through everything
else in the past it's gonna be a
challenging game I'm going to Oakland
for the game tough place to be a
visiting fan so India knows that she
India wait a minute is this a little bit
of a Raiders outfit that you're wearing
um was this that was raised but lately
you've been finding yourself intrigued
by the jet stuff it's true I just like
going on a lot of green but I do have a
dope
you don't wear you don't wear a lot of
green I don't know a lot of colors I
haven't noticed
India let's get into the Shah
yeah I think it's really neat if I do
think it's me I like me nito nito I
don't know I'm just curious what's
happening I haven't seen that maneuver
in the past what happened I like knowing
I oh you just deleted it in case it wet
so has it was it rolling the whole time
so there was a cut right you're gonna
show this part of my anger of the cut
right because I want everybody to
understand how angry I am
with cuts yeah yeah Oh interesting all
right still show this the rock I will be
double-checking Anthony asks is it wise
to form a start-up around an app or
website which will solve a problem but
without yet knowing how to monetize it
yes Anthony solving problems in utility
form is one of the greatest ways to make
a shitload of money you know for you
know I mean like absolutely like like if
you you know yes III I'm like anytime
you solve things for people anytime you
solve things for people
monetizing becomes the easiest part of
the equation
the reason I'm pausing a little and
jumping around vaynernation is I'm
rolling with this respect for Anthony
because it's Anthony because it's a it's
you know it only speaks to me not
believing that you're gonna solve the
problem to be very honest with you it
they're like I have a bad feeling in my
stomach FA I love you thank you for
supporting show I have no interest in
dropping venom on on Halloween here but
yes that's so like crazy to think about
there's a million ways to monetize if
you actually bring value to people even
if you make people laugh
you can escape the real life you make
tons of money it's called the entire
entertainment business right like like
like if you solve something tangible
like invent a car so we don't have to
take horses
yes sell it like if you make something
like you sell something that's a thing
that makes things better you monetize by
charging people for something I'm just I
don't want to answer this question is
this crazy question again the last part
even if you don't know how you're gonna
yeah if you don't know how to mom if you
don't yet know how you're going to
monetize that gonna sell it you're gonna
sell it you've solved the problem you're
gonna sell it either to a human or to a
business that wants a sponsor the fact
that we've found somebody's problem
which is the height of value in humanity
oh look I created this potion that makes
people feel better how am I ever gonna
make money I mean seriously
people we've done this for a hundred
fifty-eight shows like seriously ah I
want to feel like I might the reason I'm
asking again is not for show it's cuz
I'm trying to make sure I didn't just
you know sometimes I jumped too you know
you get you know how you guys always
talk about me cutting people off and
like keynotes it's cuz I already know
what's coming sometimes I do that so
what's the question over time yeah
forget it I heard I heard what I mean -
good Jesus Christ it's scaring the crap
out of me who is it
let me take my but yeah okay yeah that's
what you get you come in my show I'm
gonna squeeze your ass all right let's
go listen I'll bet a weird mood I'm
pissed about that first question and I
knew it was a dude you know that's a big
part of it Steve so don't get scared
no go to cliff why you're worried about
this one - just came in to do that and
dropped candies of competitors of
vaynermedia clients who's that
yeah we're gonna find out is that Kelly
he's dead he's dead
come with me dear oh hey Kelly Kelly
come let me ask you a funny question
since you've started to disrupt my show
can you come on my show and literally
dropped candy on my table from a
competitor to clients of vaynermedia
that sell candy yeah okay
yeah you're lucky you can't talk you're
real lucky cuz that's ludicrous
Andy thank you Steve thank you Steve
yeah
episode 158 one for the record books
cliff cliff asks I noticed that you
endorsed certain books and allow
yourself to be quoted on the cover I
thought you didn't read books over the
last year I have given two or three
quotes two books which is highly unusual
I see Steve's about it you know and
Steve's always cynical lucky it was you
know he already dissed me in the show
like you know he said Oh Gary you know
but you know I had explained myself to
you
so I really do it Steve's shaking his
head cuz he sees the millions that come
through requests and we always say no
cuz I don't read them and how am I gonna
put my name on it
the the only reason I put my name on a
couple of books is because I know the
human being and so that's what uh that's
as I've gotten to know jay baer and
others of that nature actually that
one's not even out yet so Lois you know
like you know these are people I know I
feel comfortable with and if you
actually look carefully at the and Steve
knows this because he helps me added
some of these quotes sometimes I won't
say things more specific about the book
I'll say Jay has a great read on the
market so I'm very careful what's saying
in this book he will change your in page
147 you know it's very Jay and so I as
I've gotten to know people over the last
you know seven to ten years and I feel
like I've gotten to know them I've felt
comfortable to give them something these
are my friends of mine who are trying to
leverage my name to do something that's
important to them and I've been careful
with the way I've positioned the quote
you know to make it more about them and
so that's it I'm really glad you asked
that question
it's the right I saw it I was like even
I was a little too scared to send it to
you and say I should answer this so but
it's the it's the right thing to do to
answer these questions that's why we
have the show not just to pick the easy
ones I like that you do that keep doing
it go even though you know what by the
way go harder like luckily lately
because they think the show is painted a
better 360 version of myself
people are dissing on me less because I
think the depth has been able to be
sucked out and so but I'm always happy
to answer the toughest of tough I mean I
don't know if I wanted yeah let's do a
hater episode we'll call it the
hater-aide episode I'm a thrill thing
actually I love answering those
questions yeah somebody hated on me and
Facebook and I saw somebody come in and
say obviously you're not watching the
show because there was like some sort of
thing about non details so what are you
looking at you just trying to make sure
you look at and you're just wondering
what he dressed up as dressed up as a
loser good costume Camille Camille asks
how would you market an HR staffing
agency Camille I would market an HR
staffing agency by creating enormous
amounts of content I would probably
reach out to the biggest HR software
companies in the world to see if they
had a blog and then email them and say
that you would love to write guest blogs
around HR dynamics and organizations I
think that would be incredible way to do
it I think guest blogging is a spamming
arbitrage that most people don't take
advantage of if you are starting any
business right now of any a a a
landscaping business a chocolate making
business a candle selling business you
go map the 15 sites that most of the
people that are likely to buy your
product are spending their time reading
and reach out to the editors and ask
them to guest blog whether an audio
forum video forum or written form
depending on your skill sets they may be
a written blog you can't write like me
and they won't take video or audio
they're gonna miss out on that
opportunity but maybe find two or three
being able to siphon that attention to
awareness around you as long as you
don't make your article about you
selling stuff you have to level up and
be a media company so for you what's the
name again Camille Camille what you need
to do is is talk about six behaviors you
look for in an employee that's been in
your organization for three years and
then you write about it instead of
saying what why using a staffing agency
is
good idea Kippy invent your best
interest it needs to be in the
audience's best interest hence this show
this show is to bring as much values it
can to build up equity to bring up value
to bring up leverage to guilt everybody
who watches and listens to this show to
buy many many books of the askgaryvee
show or tell people to watch it that
leads to speak engagements or clients of
vaynermedia or what I really care about
coz those last three things are
nice-to-haves turn everybody in the
world into a New York Jets fan when I
own them so you know I think that um by
the way not gonna be funny about that
I'm literally gonna clip that in 30
years and I'm gonna play it in the
stadium just don't you know so that I
would do that I would I would start
putting out infographic or visuals in
Instagram and use the right hashtags for
discovery around HR yeah that may sound
very weird it's probably very very very
niche but there are tons of HR people on
Instagram I mean we have a HR department
are all on Instagram so there's a lot of
hacks but it's all about content level
yourself up and act like a media company
instead of an agency put out content
that's what we do for vaynermedia I at
the forefront I'm great at it that's a
truth I'm sorry but it's true I'm great
at producing content my team is great at
helping you know that has been a huge
gateway drug to new business and
building the brand of vaynermedia then
you have to deliver because what comes
along with it especially when you're a
personal brand that is charismatic is
good-looking as I am is there's a level
of cynicism that comes along with that
so a lot of our early clients were like
yeah is this Gary Vee would a bunch of
[ __ ] behind him so then you got a
deliverer too so there's a lot of things
you have to do to be good at business
you have to bring them to the table and
then you got to serve them great food
and then they come back to your
restaurant get it you like that yeah
yeah you can't just get them to the
restaurant India see you can't just get
them to your place when they're going to
eat the porridge
it's gonna taste good we're serving
porridge yeah we're gonna start a
porridge restaurant the three of us very
those what's that you know what I bet
you porridge is not trendy but it can be
I bet you if we opened a porridge
restaurant in Williamsburg
we will dominate guys I'm not joking
right now do you want to do it
right okay hold on let's do something
crazy a [ __ ]
right now right now right now in the
askgaryvee show do we want to do a poor
inch pop-up for one week in December
from today which is almost can we get
the vaynernation who can make porridge
we can use storefront to find the
location I'm gonna be busy so it's
really on you guys I'm just exclusively
through resi reservations through
Ratzinger he's not here anymore but he
had a move they're getting bigger a
porridge pop-up December 14th then up
you love it Steve's worried because he
knows he has to put it in the work I see
you're scared of the work alright well
let's see what happens in the comments
India you take a look let's see how much
assets we might have randomly on the
spot I'm telling you is this one 58 this
and what about you guys are so far I
think that's a--fun gonna be sick
good job I is there any I'm not Andy I
need Andrew I think we need a t-shirt
for episode 115 this is going to go down
big time
no come on where's pop-up Scott asks can
you build a strong social media
following solely by engaging with your
audience or is content an absolute must
content is an absolute must
interesting listen I mean I think you
could build up something really really
interesting by being a full pledged
listener you know it depends on how you
define content which is why I kind of
wavered off if you're listening you're
gonna respond your responses are your
content so if you're asking me can you
just search engage with conversations
and put out those answers I would argue
that that's what I did you in two
thousand six seven and eight outside of
me just putting a link to the Wine
Library TV show which is a pretty big
piece of content so I can't really go
there so look I would tell you I've
disproportionately gotten value for my
engagement
but I but I think historically I've
under minded or even slightly
disrespected my content I've changed
over the last three to four years on
that point of view I realized the
content did matter I think it's a really
interesting question but I think your
answers are your content I mean very
honestly I think that's why my brand in
the business world and entrepreneur land
and startup land has gotten stronger
because I think I've positioned myself
to actually use my responses as my
content we are literally this is
literally a very meta answer we are in
the context of a show that is predicated
on me giving answers and engaging versus
meself starting around the content but
then that in itself is the depth of the
content so I think it depends on how far
you take it in the you know semantically
I would say yes you can because I think
you can put a lot of depth and and a lot
of oomph and a lot of a lot of weight
you know this is heavy a lot of weight
you know what Mike makes me do this crap
it's the worst yes because I think you
could put a lot of oomph behind the
content in response I call it counter
punching I would I would argue that
Floyd Mayweather is gonna go down as
this generations best boxer completely
predicated on your answer so take that
for what it is
why Floyd Mayweather's great a content
marketing you know I know Josh I'm gonna
bet it's Joshua
do you think his mom calls him Joshua
yeah me Tara good Josh asks is there a
question you wish people would stop
asking you Joshua it's that question
well the first one got my panties in a
bunch
no not really man to be honest with you
I'm I'm too overwhelmed with gratitude
and flattered that people want to ask me
questions that it's hard for me to get
going around the notion of judging those
questions these are questions that
everybody's in a different life
cycle in their careers and lives to
where they think I could bring value
whether they're a parent with an
entrepreneurial kid whether they're an
entrepreneur and just realize that
whether they've always been an
entrepreneur and can really associate
with my immigrant and selling hustle
I think everybody's in a different place
when when they come across my content
since so many people are discovering it
these days because there's a lot of
virality going on on face but cuz I
matter fact you know what this is a good
opportunity I put in the comments with
the share monster I really really would
love some support on Facebook I'm really
I mean look I'm selfish as like anybody
else I'm enjoying the discovery of all
these new audiences everybody who's
sharing for me and there's a consistent
crew that I want to give so much love to
everybody that's sharing
I really really appreciate and if you're
listening and watching right now if
you're listening literally pull over
your car on the highway in traffic take
out your phone go to the episode on
Facebook and hit the share button and by
the way if you did that you're the most
amazing person but if you're watching on
Facebook or a lot of you I know are
watching on YouTube
coming over to Facebook that would mean
something I would love to see I'm
curious where this call to action when
this right hook lands me in the share
lexicon for my normal average that being
said no that's it that's the answer I
have high empathy for everybody being in
a different place in their in their mind
at the moment where they feel compelled
to ask me a question and the only
emotions in my body are gratitude that's
a show you have a question all right
this is a crazy episode why don't you
come up with a question too while we're
at it and you know what go hard at it oh
very good very very very good very good
I just love what the hell that is
amazing
hi sky so good what is going on in
webisode 158 Halloween jeez alright
India asks your favorite costume you've
ever had as a kid you were just like
pumped to go out and wearing you felt so
proud and excited
that's a great question I'm gonna go
with when me and my sister dressed up as
Tom and Jerry what you know what's
interesting this is a great opportunity
I never talked about the year that we
lived in Dover New Jersey do you know
that right none of you know this it went
I always say Queens to Edison but the
truth is I don't even know why like I
just forget about that year and a half
in Dover Mamie because I don't like it
maybe the reason I love the Jets so much
is the kids were nice to me and we
played football and they want to be jet
fans and in Dover
do you so one of you've heard the story
where the kid made me drink PE out of a
Pepsi can you've heard that right Steve
you didn't hear it yeah yeah I got
picked on quite a bit because I didn't
speak English yet I was little and so uh
and so um my sister and I dressed up as
Tom and Jerry and my mom likes to tell
the story that my sister was still in a
carriage was young I would go up stairs
not going to or get the candy and then I
would always get candy for my sister
because I've been my sister's down below
it's just a story means a lot to me
about the relationship that I have with
my sister Liz and so that's the costume
that always sticks in my mind yeah
thanks Steve not as sweet go sour
go ahead Stonewood asks so he'll be
actually scared ya know so vaynermedia
has always had an or a beau growth mode
yes like always like it's always you
know bring up more clients hire more
people run out of space rinse and repeat
yes do you think there will ever be a
time where vaynermedia prioritizes depth
over width in terms of you know charging
more you know bigger fatter you know
scopes like scopes and and like you know
a subjective call on the quality of the
output right or or or and then but then
that laddering up to sort of you know
like a plateauing I'm trying you know
like like you know you know big big huge
lavish benefit packages and like things
like some agencies get
like really really really crazy with
that right where we're scrappier right
would you yeah I'm not saying that dozen
oh you're not you're not you're not but
do you think do you think Vader will
ever be like paying people two hundred
thousand dollar bonuses to be the best
creative director in the world kind of
thing well yes you're right I just want
to quantify that part of it right
exactly so it's like it's its depth over
with in terms of like sheer dollar
amounts as they relate to clients
employees benefits like all that stuff
I'm not saying it's bad right now by any
stretch right yeah no I'm not worried
about that um so I think for me the way
I run my business which is why I think
I'm running a much better business than
all these other agencies that do that is
because I think you can achieve both in
parallel so I think what I uniquely as
an arch forum good at is running both
trains so I think you could easily as
you know in the context of your question
speak to a very different level of
quality in the building from 18 months
ago right and so so if you just project
out if you think about the fact that we
didn't have a single SVP or real
creative director like any of ten years
and reals not fair a crazy director of
10 years or more experienced just 18
months ago that you can see that
happening in parallel I think that um I
think where it gets disguised is we have
people that come from gray and Ogilvy
and things that nature we also have
what's been very happy to me to see is
Eitan and Harry and and consumed and all
these people leveling up in parallel
what it gets the skies by is the thing
that's much more obvious what's much
more obvious is hyper growth of people
right it's just getting crammed when we
grow up right what's less obvious is you
know anyone's the ability to really
truly dissect 550 people's you know
depth of skill and and then there's
pockets of clients you're always gonna
variable bit depending on people Plus
hiring the right people so to me to me
the answer is it's happening in parallel
I think the only thing that makes people
think that it's happening is stop the
hiring process and then they're like oh
we're not we're not going hyper we're
we're going deeper
I think we've gone stunningly deep in 18
months by two variables one bringing the
outside talent in their 30s and 40s
right depth which is gray hairs in a lot
of people's subjective point of view and
number two the actual growth of the
people that have been in a veiner that
are totally different animals and I
think that um and I think that for every
individual it's different and I also
think that for the people that have been
here longer it's a different context
point than it is for other people you
know and so no I mean I I think as long
as I'm running the business I'm never
comfortable in thinking one has to be
done without the other I truly feel that
you're capable to do both and I think
that if you project out what's happened
in the last 18 months on the depth chart
that it's actually tremendously scalable
and gets way deeper because as you get
bigger you deploy those dollars to those
things and as far as like benefits of
packages you know I'm very I'm very
weird when it comes to bonuses I think
bonus so we've hired two people recently
that left their agencies because of
bonuses because they felt they deserved
more I think but when you have a gray
zone of I get to be the judge and jury
on the bonus I think well what is safer
is to just try to get to a number
together and I think that those things
have envelope I also think that when
you're in a fast-growing company what a
lot of employees don't um calibrate
because they shouldn't because it's very
hard for anybody to care about anything
besides what they care about for
themselves is the notion of what happens
in a 36 month window versus a 12 month
window so I've been happy to be honest
with you of getting three to four emails
in the last six months from former
employees who left because of money who
now make less money than some of their
counterparts here because vaynermedia is
growing and we've been able to you know
rise all ships and in their other places
they haven't and so those are my answers
bonus question please how fast do you
think we we max out the space at Hudson
Yards I think we might have already nice
I think you know yeah
you know I do think I do think that
every company has to bear the negatives
that come along with the positives for
their individual self around the person
that runs the company
I love insanity I like it I like when
we're like this I like I like we're
sitting this close to each other I like
it and if you were not bad if you're
somebody that really likes that and
you're spaces right with this this is
where I put this then you know Vayner
can be tricky at times though though no
question I think it's a leaders job to
adjust to his reality and I've
definitely deployed more empathy towards
the way we plan on scaling Hudson Yards
and if we need secondary offices to try
to come back a little bit on my own
selfish love of that kinetic energy
mainly predicated on because the floors
are so big so I think I'm gonna be able
to scratch my itch because they're just
big floor plates I don't beat 300-400
people comfortably on one floor and so
I'm hoping that solves that problem
so thanks T all right that's all been
one this whole episodes been one big
kind of like trying to stretch it out as
long as possible so I can really figure
out what was happening in my other
parallel mind during this show just like
I run businesses in parallel and my
other parallel mine which is like what
is really gonna happen on Sunday between
the Jets and the readers you know I
can't lie I was affected last night by
the Patriots dismantling the Dolphins
and me projecting that just the four
days earlier two Jets hung in there
pretty tight I've been really worried
about this I think the Raiders have the
kind of offense that could pose a little
bit of trouble for the Jets I also
thought the Jets played particularly
well last week and and I do think
Oakland is a very difficult place to
play they're coming off a huge win
against the Chargers arrival there's on
the road that place is gonna be rowdy
and uncomfortable though the Jets have
shown enormous composure this year with
Todd Bowles at the helm and have swung
me I've been picking the Raiders in my
head all week right up
this point and in the moment of truth I
in the moment of truth I'm gonna go 25
24 New York Jets in an absolute
nail-biter nervous scary mmm
25 24 New York Jets you keep asking
questions I want for a dramatic pause
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
happy Halloween everybody enjoy it
especially if you're lucky enough like I
am to have the kiddos it's fun
[Music]